It's hard to think of
any athlete better known
or more polarizing than Alex Rodriguez.
He's done it again.
Swatted the ball out of Arroyo's hand.
See, he joins a 3000 hit club.
A three time MVP,
14 time all star and
world series champion,
he retired in 2016 as
the highest paid player
in MLB history.
Fourth all time on the list of home runs.
But his playing career isn't
likely to be remembered
by those statistics or by
who he is or isn't dating.
A record suspension
tonight for baseball star,
Alex Rodriguez, over his use
of performance-enhancing drugs.
You say you did not do these PEDs
that they're accusing you of doing?
You're correct, Mike.
Okay.
This dude is unbelievable.
A phony to the end.
While it was the most
painful time of my life,
it may cost me the hall of fame,
and that's on me, nobody else.
I think in a weird way,
I'm gonna look back and say
that's also one of the
best things that happened.
Five years after his retirement,
Alex Rodriguez, the CEO, is
getting back into sports,
this time as an owner of
a pro basketball team.
And he wants to build more
than just a franchise,
but a legacy maybe with
a dose of redemption.
The mistakes made in baseball are done
and I can't go back and fix 'em.
I wanna keep a clean record
as a father, as a friend,
as a business person.
And because of those mistakes,
I think I have that opportunity
and I'm having the time
of my life doing it.
A-Rod, Alex Rodriguez is buying
the Minnesota Timberwolves
and the Minnesota Lynx.
The purchase price is expected to be
in the range of $1.5 billion.
You know, for me, I think
making the transition
from player to owner is something
that's very exciting to me.
I'm really excited to bring
my experience both in business
and in sports and in the locker room
and do really, really exciting things
and bring a world
championship to the city.
In April, 2021, Alex Rodriguez
joined one of the most
exclusive clubs around;
folks who own a pro sports team.
And while his name and his
fame made the headlines,
it was his business empire
that allowed him to
actually close the deal.
The easy to remember name, AROD Corp,
it's grown into a diversified
investor and operator,
taking a cue from mega firms
like Blackstone and KKR.
AROD Corp has taken a
real estate portfolio
and expanded into venture
capital and private equity
and media, and like any
business in 2021, its own SPAC.
I was more lucky than smart.
I started investing very
small in real estate,
simply as a hedge - as my
earning power would close,
my real estate would not only appreciate,
which would create more cash flow.
And then I would take that cash flow
and I would buy more real estate
and other private equity type investments
where I generated more cash flow.
So as my Yankee income went to zero,
hopefully my real estate,
my businesses would grow over time.
And while players nowadays are becoming
better and better business brands,
few are able to achieve
the scale as AROD Corp has
in such a relatively short amount of time.
But understanding how that
growth happened in business,
just like baseball, has to start at home.
Part of what I love about business
is you get to build things
from nothing, right?
Like nothing, so I had two hip surgeries
and I never wanted to be the
old guy that couldn't get up,
you know, the stairs,
so I built a flat house,
all entertainment on that side.
My room here, dad and
the girls on this side.
But it had to be one story because A -
I'm always forgetting things.
And B - I didn't wanna be like, oh my God,
I can't get up the steps
because of these hips.
Yeah, I walk around here.
I mean, first of all, the art's beautiful,
but tons of pictures of you and the girls.
And I mean, you've
really made a family life
for yourself here, tell me about that.
Well, I'll tell you what I'm not at home.
I'm not a cleanup hitter
and I'm not a CEO.
The girls remind me every
day that I work for them.
Yes.
Daddy, I can see why you play baseball.
People always ask me, what
do you do in your life?
And I say the three BS: I do
baseball, now basketball too,
business and my babies.
And that's kind of, that's my happy zone.
It's funny through a pandemic,
we spent so much time here
and in my 46 years, the
toughest time in the world
that I've witnessed.
On the other side of that,
we were in here and we felt
safe and we felt loved.
And it was like 90 days of
breakfast, lunch, and dinner
with my girls, it was a dream come true.
And they got so sick of my dad
jokes, so sick of my dancing.
Natasha, at least with
TikTok, I've been begging,
trying to bribe her to do one with me.
She goes, daddy, you
have no swag, no drip.
I'm not doing anything with you.
A-Rod's dancing
may not get his daughter's approval,
but his following on social media is huge
with nearly 4 million
followers on Instagram alone.
That number is larger than
his new basketball team,
the Yankees or the Red Sox,
not to mention any other
single baseball player,
current or former.
Who has better taste in music?
Whose room is decorated nicer?
What is it that makes you
engage the way you do in social?
You know, Jason, a lot of
that came through my time
during my suspension.
You know, I spent a whole
year serving a suspension.
And in that time,
I had an opportunity to
turn the lens inward,
and understand why I was making
some of the good choices,
the poor choices, the bad choices,
and understand kind of conversation,
understand storytelling
and is something that I'm
enjoying; is still fairly new.
We're not experts by any means,
but every time we look at
companies or opportunities
or partnerships, is data
driven and social driven,
and it's been quite a tool for us.
That suspension, which obviously people
will forever associate you with.
And there's an interesting
choice you make there
at that moment and then
in subsequent moments
to not lean out, to not retreat,
but to lean in to some extent,
and especially in the last couple years.
Tell me about that.
If you think about my career,
sure, I've hit home runs
and been part of a
world championship team,
but I'm also,
I'm fifth all time in the
history of strikeouts.
I mean that means that only four people
in the history of mankind
have failed more than me.
But I think as a result,
I've been, you know - PhD in failing,
but also an MBA of getting back up.
Looking around at his house
and his selection of cars,
it's hard to say that A-Rod
has ever really failed,
but it's striking what he has built
considering where he came from.
I was born in New York, raised in Miami.
So when I got to Miami,
I was around eight and
a half, nine years old.
My father left when I was around 10,
and at home, it was mom, my brother, Joe,
and my sister Susie.
They took the role of like,
my brother became like
the secretary of sports,
my sister became the
secretary of education
and my mom just had to -
you know, make enough money
to pay our bills.
I think, you know, my
father leaving us at 10
kinda left a huge vacant spot, right.
And I think I needed to
then kind of fill that void
by having a collection of mentors.
One of those earliest mentors
was his baseball coach, Rich Hofman,
right here at Westminster High School.
So you've walked through
this area a few times.
Oh yeah.
This brings back some
pretty cool memories.
If you hit a home run here,
it goes to the basketball
courts and the pool.
And I kind of like it,
it's kind of like got this Fenway
kind of Wrigley field.
Yeah, exactly.
Instead of the green monster,
you have the green pumps.
Yes, exactly.
Well, it's really where I
really started to understand
the power of mentorship and dreaming big.
And if you think about it,
I had one of the most
important conversations
with coach Rich Hofman.
And that happened at 15, the
first day I walked on campus.
He goes, "Look, Alex, you're
gonna come in this year.
You're gonna have a good year.
And then you're going
to the Junior Olympics
to represent the US.
You'll do well there,
you'll get much stronger.
By that time, you'll be like
the top junior in the country.
And then your senior year,
you're gonna be the number
one pick in the country
and then you're gonna be
off to the big leagues."
Coach, you're talking to me?
He goes, "Yeah, I'm talking to you, Alex."
And Jason, I went home that
night and I believed him.
It just like, it changed
my complete vision on me
and my future.
And then I did everything in
my power not to let coach down.
So as a leader today,
when I have young people,
it's my job to not only
give 'em the opportunity,
but to push them and push them
to a level where they now see
the world in a different
way about themselves.
That prediction came true.
In the 1993 MLB draft, Rodriguez
was selected first overall
by the Seattle Mariners.
And while his playing career
was just getting started,
by the age of 22,
he'd invest in his first
piece of real estate.
It was what I knew best.
My mother, she wasn't a homeowner.
We were renters, right?
We were tenants.
And every 18 months we would move
because the landlord would
always raise the rents.
And I remember as a young kid saying,
boy, if I can ever trade
places with the landlord
and they can be the tenant,
that would be amazing.
I bought my first duplex
and then I owned that for a few years.
I sold it for double.
Bought fourplex, eightplex,
60 units, and off we went.
When it came to those first investments,
you know, whenever he does something,
he's going in at a hundred percent.
This is Jose Gomez;
everyone calls him Pepi.
Along with Jose More,
he's the co-CEO of Newport
Property Construction,
and also a childhood friend of Rodriguez.
From 2004 to 2007,
we ended up acquiring 5,100
units between Florida and Texas.
We renovated 'em.
He would buy 'em, I would renovate them.
And, you know, the rest was history.
Being a real estate investor,
especially in high growth
markets like Florida,
well, it hasn't been a straight line up
for the past two decades.
Miami's high rise condos are monuments
to a burst property bubble.
Almost half of Florida
mortgages are underwater.
As we had this run up to 2007,
prices were going up like this,
and then it just fell off a cliff.
The great recession crushed owners
and developers alike.
Few were immune,
except those that had
other sources of income
to take advantage of falling prices.
Income like say one of the
richest baseball contracts
in history.
Our huge advantage was
that Alex had W2 income
coming in from playing and
we had that stay in power.
So we were able, even
when things started going,
you know, south for some people,
we were able to grow within
those difficult times.
Monument Capital Management
has done more than 60 deals since 2012,
worth more than $900 million.
The extent of that ambition
in real estate is evident here
at Grand Station in downtown Miami.
The 30 story residential tower,
complete with a sprawling
amenity floor and pool
has sweeping views of downtown.
It's a bet on Miami's growth
and it's a bet that's looking smarter
as Wall Street firms and other
companies look southward.
People always question Miami,
"why do people live there?"
There's not any great jobs.
You know, we don't have a lot
of financial services here.
We don't have anybody
manufacturing anything,
but that's changing.
People see this as a very
cool place to live and work.
Now before was, oh, it was
always a cool place to live,
but where are you gonna work?
Now it's okay, the jobs are here first.
Cool place to visit in the past.
Right, yeah.
And now each pocket
is being built out.
I think Art Basel years
and years ago started that
and then there have
been a course of events
that have followed that
continue to enrich Miami.
And I would say we're
still early as a city.
But while Miami maybe home base,
Rodriguez's most aggressive
current real estate project
is buying, renovating, and
renting out single family homes
in markets across the country.
And in this case, he's not just emulating
some of the world's biggest investors,
but also getting into business with them,
including real estate
legend, Barry Sternlight.
Just as behemoth like Blackstone
have amassed Single Family Homes.
Rodriguez, through the
Tiber Capital Group,
has snapped up 5,000 homes so far.
We think we're still in the early earnings
of single family housing.
Rents are going up about 18 to 19%.
Once we find something, then...
You know, this I learned
from Warren Buffet is,
you know, be disciplined but
when you find your pitch,
you know, don't go for
a single or a double,
you know, go in and go in big
and that's exactly what
we've done multifamily,
and now with single family houses.
Going big has required Rodriguez
to build a team around him
and he is opted for a
delicate balance of homegrown
and outside hires.
On the one side, friends
dating back to childhood
and adolescents, including
Erin, Pepi, and Jose.
On the other newer additions,
such as Kelly Laferriere,
Stuart Zook, David Becker, and Lisa Peier.
Managing the chemistry among
the small and growing team
is akin to the elusive
intangibles Rodriguez saw
in clubhouses when he was a player.
Getting it right, well,
that's the difference
between a champion and an also-ran.
Lisa, take it away.
Sure, so I think next we're gonna have
an update on Timberwolves from Kelly.
Awesome.
And VCP as it relates
to Timberwolves and Glen
Cool, so team's 11 and 11,
and one exciting development
is the 12/17 game
against the Lakers is going to be on ESPN.
So we were not on the ESPN
schedule, and now we are.
At the AROD Corp offices,
you'll notice the memorabilia,
the pictures of famous athletes,
the realtime social data being
displayed on the TV wall,
but you'll also see pictures of Rodriguez
with some of the biggest
businessmen in the world.
Alex has become a sponge.
And he started that as an active player.
When he was on the road,
he would go and visit the
Jerry Reinsdorfs of the world
in his uniform and ask
them business questions.
And he surrounded himself
with really good smart people.
The wide network is
critical in sourcing deals,
including in the venture world
were where the AROD portfolio
has included more than 60 companies,
brands like Hims and
Hers, Gopuff and UFC gyms,
but having the best team doesn't
mean you win every at bat.
Their SPAC, SLAM Corp,
was recently negotiating
a roughly $3 billion deal to merge
with collectible company
Panini that didn't materialize
after Panini stumbled.
SLAM's still in search of a target,
but Rodriguez's belief in
taking swings, striking out,
and hitting big is also the
same way he would end up
with his own sports franchise.
JLo and A-Rod are angling
to buy the New York Mets.
They're not just angling,
I mean, they are in the process
of putting the money together.
Rodriguez, along with a group
that included his
then-girlfriend, Jennifer Lopez,
entrepreneur Mark Lore and several others,
mounted a bid against front runner
and hedge fund billionaire,
Steven A. Cohen.
These guys are all rich.
You know, as far as we go,
they've made millions
and millions of dollars,
but we're talking about billions here.
The very public process ultimately landed
A-Rod and JLo's consortium
as the runner up
with Cohen buying the
team for $2.4 billion.
We are a little bit depressed about it.
We don't like to lose, and,
you know, we were really,
we started getting really excited
and thinking about what could be.
And so when it just sort
of came to a complete halt,
there was sort of like
this shock to the system.
We were sort of depressed and down.
Mark Lore is a New York born businessman
who most recently had been a
senior executive at Walmart.
He gotten there by selling
his company, jet.com
to the mega retailer and
stayed on to run that division.
And while A-Rod's partnership
with JLo would come undone,
he formed a close business
and personal connection
with Lore that's lasted.
House rules, man, I told you no ties, man.
That's my favorite tie!
You grew up in a sort of very similar way,
and from very humble beginnings.
I love Mark, I love him like a brother,
and he's a great partner
and a great friend.
And, you know, he sleeps at
my house, I sleep at his house
and we both have this
drive and this mission
that I want him to win in the worst way
and I think he does the same for me.
I wanna show you this clip
because it spoke to me a lot
about the depth of your relationship.
Yeah, I think this is getting
a little bit deeper now,
but I think it comes down
to our dads, you know.
We both felt like, you know,
we had something to prove
in order to sort of feel loved really.
And when you did something spectacular,
you felt, oh, maybe, you know.
And I think he similarly had felt that too
where if you wanted to feel
loved, you had to do big things.
What do you make of that?
I never thought about it that way,
but I know that when my father left at 10,
it left a huge hole in
my heart, in my stomach,
and I knew that I had to do better.
And I think before therapy,
it was probably better
for the wrong things.
I think post and current, I
look at it as just my purpose.
But I also know that I'm enough now.
And probably before
that, I thought I wasn't.
The deep connection with Lore
led to a new $400 million
venture fund called VCP,
and notably allowed them to quickly pivot
to a successful deal in sports ownership;
their pursuit of the
Minnesota Timberwolves
and Minnesota Lynx.
He called me and he said,
"Hey, are you serious about this?"
He said, "I won't do it unless
you're serious about it."
And I said, I'm serious about it.
Are you serious about it?
And again, a minute
conversation, we're both in,
and we've probably got the
deal done in six or seven days.
NBA ownership has radically transformed
in the past decade.
Its tech executives like
Steve Ballmer and Joe Tsai
and Wall Street investors
like Mark Lasry, Josh Harris,
and Tony Ressler have snapped up teams.
There's a supply demand
imbalance where anyone,
you know, most people, if they could,
would own a professional sports
team and there's, you know,
very high barriers to entry
and, you know, very limited supply.
In the case of the Timberwolves,
Glen Taylor bought the team
in 1994 for $88 million.
The sale to Rodriguez's
group values the franchise,
paired with the four
time WNBA champion, Lynx,
at $1.5 billion.
And that's relatively affordable.
A-Rod's old team, the Yankees,
is worth more than $5 billion
according to several estimates.
And while ownership is changing,
so too are the players.
I think players today
want more in every sport.
They're into fashion.
They wanna be good investors.
They wanna learn about venture.
The NBA players today
that I've been around,
some of them are more prepped at 20
than some of the guys that
I played with at were 50
and meeting with our athletes
and talking about business
and them reaching out to me,
it's great, it's humbling,
and it's really impressive.
And if anything,
their ownership has maybe
gotten too close to the players
with the team being fined $250,000
for violating league rules
with an off season workout
in A-Rod's hometown of Miami.
But buying a basketball
team instead of the Mets
might accomplish a goal he
thought was unreachable,
actually making him cool to his daughters.
I recently went to a Sixers
game and my little one,
Ella, who's 13, she goes,
"Dad, I really like this basketball thing.
Like one day maybe I get to
run the business here one day."
Really?
And I was the like,
oh my God, that's like the
greatest thing I've ever heard.
And she goes, "You know, it's like,
you know, baseball's a little
slower, but this stuff,
I can really get into it."
I said, whoa, baseball's great too.
It's just, you know, it's
more of a thinking man's game.
It's like chess, not checkers.
And she goes, "Yeah, yeah, yeah, whatever.
I don't like chess either but," she says,
"This basketball thing,
I have like real passion,
is like the entertainment
and I have thoughts
and I have ideas and I,"
and she thinks much more like a producer.
She likes dancing.
And I mean, to me, that's just like,
boy, that's the great thing
about sports and music.
It brings people together.
And it certainly did
that for us that night.
You have built this amazing business.
You know, there are people
who are watching this
who's like this guy!
You know, it's like
they'll always remember you
for your baseball career
and a baseball career
that was this controversial,
to say the least.
You could be living on
an island somewhere,
you don't have to do this.
I thought about tapping
out a bunch of times.
I would wake up in the middle of the night
and being tears going,
like how in the world
do I get Pocket Aces and figure
out a way to screw this up?
That was a very painful time for me.
And I think the year suspension allowed me
to not only put lipstick
on the house and paint it
and fix the windows,
it allowed me to tear
the entire house down
and start building it one brick at a time.
And in that process, I became
even closer to my daughters.
And when I think about those mistakes
and the lessons learned, I think about,
okay, but you know what?
That was baseball.
And I had good moments and
I had very tough moments,
but clean slate, when it
comes to being a father,
to being a partner, to
being a businessman,
to being a friend.
So I draw some incredible
motivation through,
man, something that sucked,
something that I did to myself.
I say to myself, in the darkest hour,
boy, if I ever get another opportunity,
I'm not gonna screw that up again.
And I'm trying my best not to do that.